.
WILL.
WILL: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE LONE STAR STATE STEPPING UP
PUSH FOR ENHANCED BORDER
SECURITY PLANNING TO DEPLOY
ARMORED MILITARY VEHICLES TO TEN
LOCATIONS ALONG THE BORDER AND
COMES DAYS AFTER GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTT INVOKED THE INVASION
CLAUSE OF THE STATE'S
CONSTITUTION.
LET'S ASK DEPUTY SECRETARY KEN.
LET'S START WITH THE NEWS ROOM
THIS MORNING AND I'LL READ A BIT
FROM GOVERNOR ABBOTT'S LETTER
AND LET'S GET YOUR REACTION TO
WHAT HE SAID AND YOUR FOLLOW UP
ACTIONS.
THE LETTER SAID YOUR SILENCE IN
THE FACE OF REPEATED PLEAS ARE
DEAFENING YOUR REFUSAL TO LOOK
AT THE BORDER TO SEE FIRSTHAND
THE AI DON'T SAY AND OPEN BORDER
POLICIES HAVE MADE AN
UN-PRECEDENTED CRISIS AND CAUSED
US TO INVOKE THE CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY TO PROTECT OURSELVES.
TEXAS WILL DEPORT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS TO THE BORDER.
TELL ME YOUR REACTION.
>> WELL, TO THE BORDER IS NOT
DEPORTING.
AND UNDERSTAND DEPORT IS AN
IMMIGRATION WORD TO BE CLEAR.
THIS ISN'T IMMIGRATION LAW AND
TEXAS HAS AUTHORITY UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION TO PROTECT ITSELF,
IT'S SOVEREIGNTY AND BOARDERS
WHEN IT IS INVADED.
WELL, GOVERNOR ABBOTT
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT HAD TEXAS IS
BEING INVADED AND ACKNOWLEDGED
THE CONSTITUTION GIVES HIM THE
ABILITY TO PROTECT THEMSELVES,
AND THIS IS A WAR POWER.
THAT'S AWKWARD WORDING BUT
THAT'S WHAT THE FOUNDERS PUT IN
THE CONSTITUTION.
THE KEY ISN'T FORCE.
IT'S NOT TANKS AND PLANES BUT TO
STOP PEOPLE AND TURN THEM AROUND
AND PUT THEM BACK INTO MEXICO
BUT HE SAID TO THE BORDER.
THE BURDENER TEXAS IS THE MIDDLE
OF THE RIO GROUND AND HAVE TO
CROSS THE RIVER AND PUT THEM
BACK IN MEXICO AND DO IT AT
SCALE TO SLOW THE FLOW OF PEOPLE
CROSSING THE BORDER ILLEGALLY OR
THIS WILL BE AS MEANINGLESS AS
18 MONTHS OF OPERATION LONE
STAR.
IT'S BEEN 18 MONTHS AND THEY'VE
SPENT $4 BILLION AND THE FLOW OF
ILLEGAL ENTRANCE HAS GONE UP,
NOT DOWN.
UP.
SO THIS IS THE ONE STEP HE
CLEARLY ACKNOWLEDGES HE HAS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY BUT NOT
DOING THE ONE THING TO SLOW THE
FLOW.
WILL: WHICH WHICH IS TO REMOVE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS BACK ACROSS
TO THE MEXICAN SIDE OF THE
BORDER.
YOUR ARGUMENT, KEN, IS HE'S
USING THE CORRECT WORDING IN
DECLARING AN INVASION, HE'S NOT
EXECUTING THE ACTIONS THAT THAT
POWER WOULD ENVIEW THE STATE OF
TEXAS.
DOES ANYTHING AND THIS IS THE
QUESTION I WANTED TO FOLLOW UP
SECONDARILY WITH YOU, DOES
ANYTHING SINCE THAT ANNOUNCEMENT
CONVINCE YOU, BECAUSE WE
MENTIONED HE'S GOING TO DEPLOY
THE ON WARD TRUCKS TO THE
BORDER.
DOES ANYTHING SINCE THE DECK LA
RATION OF INVASION SUGGEST HIS
ACTIONS WILL LIVE UP TO
HOPEFULLY YOUR EXPECTATIONS AND
THE POWER OF DECLARING INVASION?
>> NO, AND THE WORD I GET BACK
CHANNEL FROM THE DPS, WHICH IS
THEIR STATE POLICE IS NOTHING
HAS CHANGED.
THIS IS ANOTHER PRESS EFFORT,
ANOTHER PHOTO OP BY GOVERNOR
ABBOTT AND THAT COMES FROM
PEOPLE WHO ARE DETERMINED NOT TO
DO IT.
THE LEADERSHIP OF DPS, STEVE
MIKRO IN PARTICULAR, DOES NOT
WANT TO DO THIS.
AS LONG AS STEVE MCCRAW IS
THERE, GREG ABBOTT WILL NOT MOVE
THEM BACK INTO MEXICO.
WILL: WHY IS THAT?
>> HE VEHEMENTLY OPPOSES IT AND
IT FINDS A WAY NOT TO WORK.
WE HOPE GOVERNOR ABBOTT GETS
SERIOUS ABOUT THIS AND TEXAS
COULD MAKE A BIG DENT IN THE
FLOW FROM MEXICO BUT HE'S NOT
DONE THAT.
WILL: IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT PEOPLE'S WORDS
MEAN AND WHAT THAT THEN MEANS
FOR OUR POLICY AND OUR EXECUTION
AND OUR ACTIONS AND I APPRECIATE
YOU FOCUSSINGS ON THAT THIS
MORNING, KEN.
WE'VE PAID ATTENTI